je m'appelle Colleen English, je suis la
surintendante des
communautés de développement durable et des
relations extérieures avec Diavik en ligne, il y a
plusieurs choses qui
sont faites autour de la fermeture, ce qui est l'une des
plus fortes, donc encore une fois un
héritage négatif assez lourd dans le Nord autour des
esprits et  en particulier les esprits fermés
laissant derrière eux des sortes de catastrophes environnementales
et ce genre de choses et
donc c'était un autre élément important de notre
évaluation environnementale était de commencer à
parler de fermeture maintenant, commençons à
planifier la fermeture maintenant pendant que vous
développez la ligne, donc une grande partie du
la conception de l'esprit était en fait orientée
vers la fermeture il y a quelques
éléments clés nous avons un plan provisoire de fermeture
et de remise en état que nous avons toujours
eu nous avons commencé avec un plan de fermeture se
terminera essentiellement avec le plan de fermeture
mais ce plan va évoluer et
changer au fur et à mesure que notre esprit progresse, ce plan
va certainement évoluer et changer
et nous venons donc de traverser  h notre dernière
soumission notre plus récente soumission du
plan provisoire de remise en état de la fermeture
qui a été approuvé par l'office des terres et des
eaux de KZ et qui dit essentiellement que vous
savez pour ce stade de la vie de la mine,
c'est ce que nous avons prévu, mais nous
avons encore ces questions qui  nous
devons répondre afin de savoir pleinement à quoi
ressemblera cette mine lorsqu'elle sera
fermée, beaucoup de ces questions
reviennent aux préoccupations de la communauté et et
vraiment juste essayer de travailler avec les
communautés pour dire à quoi ressemble ce
paysage quand nous '  Vous êtes parti, vous
savez quels sont certains de
ces éléments clés pour l'environnement
qui vont être liés
à la façon dont la faune utilise la zone, vous savez à
quoi ressemble le paysage
en général, donc si vous parlez d'un rocher
le tas, vous savez, est-il lisse et rond pour
que les caribous puissent le monter et le franchir
ou le gardez-vous en blocs et raide
pour qu'ils ne s'en approchent pas, vous savez quelles
sont ces sortes de considérations que
le  les communautés ont ce qu'elles veulent
voir à la fin lorsque la mine sera fermée
afin que le plan provisoire de fermeture et de remise en état
conduise éventuellement à un
plan de fermeture final et c'est quelque chose sur
lequel nous commençons vraiment à générer des
discussions avec les communautés
pour essayer de  commencez-les à réfléchir sur la
piste de savoir à quoi voulez-vous que l'
esprit ressemble en moi et à quoi ressemblera ce
paysage pour vous qui
voudrez peut-être revenir en arrière et l'utiliser bien
après la fin de la mine en ce moment quand
vous regardez  à cette image de votre esprit,
vous saurez que l'une des
caractéristiques les plus importantes du problème est cette
fosse à ciel ouvert, ce qui va se passer était que oui, donc
le plan est que les fosses seraient
remplies d'eau une fois que c'est fait, donc l'une
des choses  dont on a parlé
est en quelque sorte de laver les murs de tous
les résidus qui pourraient se trouver sur les
parois des fosses qui ont
été soulevées par les communautés, puis
les fosses seraient remplies d'eau afin que
nous puissions  pomper de l'eau dans les fosses, l'
eau resterait dans ces fosses
afin que nous soyons convaincus que la
qualité de l'eau est suffisamment bonne pour être
reliée au lac de Gras, puis
le plan est de percer les digues de la
fosse, donc essentiellement pour  découper des sections de
la digue afin qu'ensuite toute cette
zone soit reconnectée à la vie DeGraw
telle qu'elle était avant, donc évidemment, c'était en
quelque sorte sous l'eau avant et elle serait à
nouveau sous l'eau à la fermeture, puis des
morceaux de l'île seraient laissés comme
des îles comme nous y étions auparavant, puis une
partie de cette zone ici est en fait un
habitat de poissons conçu de sorte que l'habitat de poissons artificiel soit
essentiellement
laissé comme des zones moins profondes que les poissons peuvent
utiliser pour le frai, c'est donc le plan